how is it that two entrepreneurs can
start a business at the exact same time
and two years later one of them is 20
times as big as the other one and how
can an entrepreneur achieve success
make some big risk lose it all and then
start over again and then achieve
back to the same level of success in a
fraction of the time compared to
somebody who's starting from scratch
that's the question that i want to
answer today in this video and if you
don't know who i am my name is alex from
mozy i own acquisition.com it's a
portfolio of companies it's about 85
million a year and i have nothing to
sell you and the reason i make these
videos is because i was once broke and
there are a lot of people who are broke
and i do not want you to be one of them
when you are scaling a company one of
the difficult pieces of this because
i've tried to think back like why is it
that every single time we start another
company or require an interest
everything goes so much faster even when
the strategy itself is not that complex
and so think about this structurally
most business strategies are not
complicated find something that's
something
find something people want charge a lot
of money for it and deliver that thing
really well so much so that they tell
other people about your product it's not
overwhelmingly complex to consider the
execution is difficult but the concept
is not and so a lot of people think
they're going to win on strategy when
they're starting a business when you
could have two people who have lawn care
companies and one person has a longer
company worth a billion dollars one
person that can barely break five
thousand dollars a month it's not
because the strategy is significantly
different it's just the execution how is
it that an entrepreneur or two
entrepreneurs can start at the exact
same time and one can be get 10 20 30
times faster or when you start over
again you can always skip these steps to
get to your level of incompetence my
theory around this comes down to pattern
recognition and let me explain it's not
just pattern recognition from the
perspective that you have strategies or
something that you're you're recognizing
but actually patterns in people and so
i'm going to give this a quick story to
drive this this point home i have
struggled for the last decade to find uh
an assistant and so it's one of the
things i'm actually you know a little
embarrassed about but i i've gone over
seven on assistance um so much so the
point that i was just i almost kind of
gave up just even trying to find an
assistant and until recently i every
time i had an assistant it just always
right off the bat it just never felt
like right and i always was like yeah
maybe it'll get better it'll get better
at it and they just never really did and
the problem was that i didn't know what
it looks like when it's right and so in
the videos that i talk about i use the
word the term ideal scene i don't know
what the ideal scene of this
dynamic looks like when we are scaling
companies right and i'll tell you what i
found out there in a second but like
when we're scaling companies what we
have to do is pay down ignorance tax of
knowing what ideal scene looks like
which is where speed comes from having
people who have outside eyes look in who
already do know what i steal ideal scene
looks like so you can skip steps faster
and so i'll give you an example what
this looks like in real life like for me
in the role of executive assistant thank
god that like for me it wasn't a
necessary thing to continue to grow the
businesses now that i have one i don't
ever really want to live life without
one but
the entire time i kept bringing people
in i didn't know what to look for we do
hiring you know we do the hiring process
we do an onboarding and training process
they never really got up to speed or we
never really got in sync and then i'd
slowly kind of fall away there would be
distance and then it became kind of
awkward and then i would end up having
to cut the relationship and so in this
instance we immediately synced up i
really like the person i trust the
person and they are so proactive in all
aspects of my life that i just sit down
and start working and then she places
things in front of me i'm like hey i got
13 minutes she's like cool do this i'm
like i've got you know 18 minutes here
she's like cool do this and do this and
every time i'm done i'm like hey what
else should i do she's like boom and so
we meet based on the priorities that i
have and then she has this big stack and
knows how long every every one of these
things takes because i talk to her about
how long i think the task will take and
then as i have openings we slot it in so
it's like i wake up and i'm just
crushing work until the end of the day
because i know that the amount of time
that's been allotted for each of the
tasks is the appropriate amount of time
and so and if i do finish early i get
another task done right and so we can we
can we can crush stuff but it's not so
much that this is the importance of the
executive assistant more so that it took
so long for me to get one and now that i
do have one i know that i will not ever
not have one for the rest of my life
because now i know what ideal scene
looks like i know what to look for
within the roles that exist in the
company there are going to be these gaps
as you're growing you know probably on
some level that you might need somebody
who's going to be a director of
marketing you might know on some level
that you need somebody who can be a
director of sales you might know and
some level you need a director of hr
director of finance director of customer
success director of product you know
director of you know all these different
things right legal maybe and so these
heads of the companies have to come in
and so there's two different ideal
scenes that you have to know number one
is what sequence these people will best
fit and you hire because you don't hire
them all at once obviously as you're
scaling but the second is what does that
person look like not just like what does
the role do but what is somebody who's
very good at this role look like what
we're doing is looking at people who are
exceptional at the role and saying how
can i find something just like this and
that
is why people can go so much faster
because once you have figured out what a
sales director looked like who's good or
a salesman who's good or marketing
director who's good
you can find and duplicate that pattern
again fundamentally like this is like my
belief in terms of speed of scale is
that you do not know what the people
look like and it's one of the issues
that we deal with the most with our
portfolio companies so the portfolio
companies
that we work with are almost all
e-learning and coaching type businesses
um and service-based businesses
and we work with those companies and
they're like hey you know my mom can do
some math and so she's gonna be our uh
our controller like i don't i don't
think she's what that's not that's not
ideal scene that's not what this looks
like like just being able to do math is
not i mean it's a requisite but it's not
all of the requisites for becoming a
really good controller and to the same
degree it's like hey we've got our top
salesman he's gonna become sales
director like um i don't know if that's
necessarily a good idea he might just be
a really high level individual
contributor and not a very good sales
leader or sales manager the big mistakes
that happen and they are so costly
because of the time in two ways one it
takes time to bring these people on
board and then it takes time to figure
out that they're not good takes time to
off-board them and then the whole while
you're not growing because that that
whole cycle took the time if you had the
right person all of the aspects of that
department would be growing rather than
staying the same or shrinking right and
you could have just moved on and started
as as that department was growing moved
on and started filling another role with
the right person and then that
department started growing instead you
have to spend all this time inordinately
on this department that you mishired for
and then find someone else to replace
and you couldn't even hire the next
person you need and so when you're
thinking about this and this is the big
takeaway for everyone is that speed
comes from picking the right people and
knowing what right looks like and don't
get me wrong you're gonna make mistakes
we all make mistakes but i can tell you
that it's very easy to know when someone
is not a stud it's harder to know if
someone comes in and starts as a stud
and then goes down but i can tell you
that every single stud that i've had
every single a player i've had i've
known they were in a player within the
first couple days and so i've had eight
players who then stopped being a players
but if someone is not an a player up
front i've never had someone become an a
player and so your tolerance or my
tolerance for non-excellence continues
to decrease in time so that i cannot
waste the time of trying to figure out
whether this person is going to help me
grow the business in terms of the thing
that is probably getting in your way
it's your tolerance is too high for
people who are not that good and a
misunderstanding of what the roles look
like that you need to hire and so the
things that you need to do are to
decrease your tolerance and find people
who already know what this role looks
like when it is excellent all right so
don't take advice from people who are
one step ahead of you right because they
might not know i mean how many times
have you heard someone say oh i've got
this new so-and-so they're so great and
then
four months later they're like oh no i
actually got rid of that person it
didn't work out don't listen to people
who are like two steps you know one step
ahead or six months ahead like it's not
useful find somebody who's built
multiple of the types of departments
you're looking for scaled it for a long
period of time and then that person will
be able to share what the what the
requisites are for the roles that you're
looking for all right so anyways
motivation lots of love keep rocking and
i'll see you guys in the next video keep
crushing